[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم زين
العابدين توفيق وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه
تقع احداث وتتفاعل اخرى ونبدا من هذه
الصور المباشره من موسكو التي اعلنت احباط
محاولاته لتخريب محطهين ذويتين روسيتين
تقول ان المخابرات الاوكرانيه تقف خلف هذه
المحاوله ومن موسكو الى كييف وهذه الصور
المباشره كيف قالت انه هجومها المضاد
المرتقب ضد روسيا بدا بالفعل اتعلن نيتها
استهدافها القوات الروسيه وخطوطاتها
وهذه صور من طهران نتابع من طهران اشارات
ترسلها ايران بشان افق الحل الدبلوماسي
لبرنامجناوي والمفاوضات الجاريه بشانه
وحديثها ايضا عن تبادل الرسائل مع واشنطن
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
رغم نفيها المسؤوليه عن الهجمات المتزايده
داخل روسيا كييف تؤكد ان عمليات الهجوم
المضاد يجري تنفيذها بالفعل ضد القوات
الروسيه وامداداتها الفلسفه يؤكد لاعداد
لبدء تدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين على
مقاتلات اف 16 ويقول ان بناء قوه جويه
اوكرانيه سيستغرق وقتها وموسكو تبدا في
نشر الاسلحه النوويه غير الاستراتيجيه في
بيلاروسيا
[تصفيق]
بعد كشف ايران عن صاروخ بالست جديد واشنطن
تستنكر وتؤكد ان الدبلوماسيه هي افضل
السبل لمنع طهران من حيازه سلاح النووي
والطهران تعلن احراز تقدم جيد بشان
المفاوضات النوويه وتبادل رسائل غير
مباشره مع واشنطن الجيش الاسرائيلي يوضح
ان التهديد اعتقادته لايران لا تعني انه
بسبب شن حرب
بعد اعلان وكالات استخبارات غربيه تسلل
قراصنه تدعمهم بايجين الى شبكات البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه الامريكيه الصين تنفي اي
علاقه لها وتتهم الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها بالتضليل عواشنطن تقول ان الصين
تملك القدرات لشن هجمات سيبرانيه قد تعطل
البنيه التحتيه الامريكيه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصتهم
الرقميه ناقشنا هذه الاشارات من طهران
بشاري التقدم في مفاوضات الملف النووي
الايراني وايضا ناقشنا تاكيد المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه امانه واشنطن بالتواصل
الى حل دبلوماسيه بشان هذا الملف
والاستطلاعي ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي هل تؤتي
الجهود الدبلوماسيه اكلها ويستمر
التفاوض وجاءت النتائج على النحو التالي
20% تقريبا قالوا ان التقدم في المفاوضات
سيستمر بينما قال حوالي 50% ان
الدبلوماسيه لن تقلل بالنجاح وحوالي 30%
راوا انها ستنجح ولكن بعد وقت طويل
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات من
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز الكيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
ونتابع في الحصاد ايضا
في بوزنيقه المغربيه اجواء ايجابيه بعد
توافق وفضي التفاوض على النقاط المتعلقه
بانتخاب رئيس وبرلمان جديد لليبيا
[موسيقى]
اذا البدايه باخر التطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث افاد مكتب مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه للجزيره ان الهجوم المضاده على
القوات الروسيه هو عباره عن سلسله من
العمليات التي يجري تنفيذها بالفعل وليس
خطوه واحده وان العمليات تشمل تدمير مصادر
الدعم الخلفي وتشمل عمليات الاستطلاع حول
الجيش الروسي ومواقع
كلامه المسؤول الاوكراني ياتي بعد اسابيع
ارتفعت فيها وتيره الهجمات على الاراضي
وفي الاراضي الروسيه وهو ما يطرح اسئله
بشان استراتيجيه كييف تجاه ما يعرف
بالهجوم المضاد تتهم روسيا اوكرانيا
بتنفيذ هذه الهجمات بينما تنفي كيف
مسؤوليتها التقرير التالي يسلط الضوء على
ابرز هذه الهجمات وعلى سياقاتها
هل بدا الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
كريحاته وتسريبات الاستخباراتيه ان يبدا
ما يعرف الهجوم المضاد في الربيع على ان
يتركز في شرق اوكرانيا وجنوبها لكنها
بدايات الصيف وتصعيد الاخير لم يكن في
اوكرانيا بل في روسيا نفسها تتهم موسكو
كيف بشن هذه الهجمات لكن كيف تنفي علاقتها
بها وتحيرها الى روس مناهضين للسلطات في
موسكو ليس اخر هذه الهجمات استهداف من
وصفهم جهاز امن الدوله الروسي بالمخربين
الاوكرانيين عمود طاقه كهربائيه فيلينجراد
للطاقه النوويه غرب روسيا اضافه الى
استهداف خطوط للطاقه في محطه كالينين
بمقاطعه تير شمال غرب موسكو يتزامن هذا
الهجوم مع اعلان حاكم مقاطعه بيلوغرود
الروسيه عن اسقاط مسيره اوكرانيه قرب
المدينه التي شهدت قبل ايام قليله هجوما
وصفته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بالعبر للحدود
نفدته مجموعات عسكريه اوكرانيه قوميه
باستخدام معدات عسكريه غربيه صنع بينما
قال ما يسمى بفيلق المتطوعين انه نفذ
عمليه ناجحه في المنطقه بل توعد بمزيد من
الضربات ملامح هذا التصعيد في العمق
الروسي ربما بدات تتشكل مع استهداف
الكرملين بطائره مسيره بدايه الشهر الجاري
ووفق ما نقلته نيويورك تايمز اخيرا عن
مسؤولين امريكيين فان ذلك الهجوم كان على
الارجح بتدبير وحدات عسكريه او
استخباراتيه اوكرانيه رغم نفي كيف المتكرر
استهداف الكرملين لم يقف التصعيد على هجوم
الكرملين بل شمل كذلك استهداف مصفاه
اليسكي للنفط بطائره مسيره لمرتين خلال
يومين فقط ناهيك عن الاستهداف المستمر
لشبه جزيره القرم وليس اخيرا استهداف
الاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود اذ اعلنت
موسكو ان سفينه استطلاع عسكريه روسيه
تعرضت لهجوم نفذته كيف باستخدام زوارق
مسيره
رسميا لا يدعم الغرب اي هجوم على الاراضي
الروسيه وسبق للبيت الابيض ان كرر ذلك
وامتنع عن تصدير اسلحه الى اوكرانيا يصل
مداها الى الاراضي الروسيه وفي اخر تصريح
له اكد البيت الابيض انه لا يؤيد استخدام
المعدات العسكريه الامريكيه لشن هجمات
داخل روسيا رغم ما نقلته نيويورك تايمز
بان القوات المواليه لاوكرانيا استخدمت
مدرعات امريكيه هنا يبرز الحديث عن طائرات
اف 16 الامريكيه التي وافقت واشنطن على
تزويد كييف بها فهل سيكون دورها دفاعيا
فقط ام قد تستخدمها اوكرانيا في تنفيذ
هجمات داخل الاراضي الروسيه لا جواب واضحا
بعد لكن ما يبدو واضحا ان سلسله هجمات
نفذت داخل الاراضي الروسيه اخيرا وهذا ما
يحيل الى تصريحات مستشار الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه الذي قال ان روسيا لا تستوعب
ما يحدث فعمليات المقاومه تتوسع في مناطق
الروسيه وهو يرى ان الهجوم المضاده سلسله
من العمليات يجري تنفيذها بالفعل وليس
خطوه واحده اما موسكو فتقول على لسان وزير
دفاعها ان الرد على اي توغلات جديده عبر
الحدود سيكون قاسيا
في الاثناء قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
الاوكرانيين على الجيل الرابع من طائرات
16 قد يبدا خلال الاسابيع المقبله واشار
الى ان الدنمارك وهولندا ستتولى يعني
قياده برنامج التدريب
لعبت من
تحدثت الى وزيري دفاع هولندا والدنمارك
بشان ما هو ضروري لوضع خطه لتدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين
وتحدثنا ايضا عن حقيقه ان التدريب هو مجرد
عنصر واحد
ولكي تكون لديك القدره فانت بحاجه الى
صيانه ووسائل دعم واستمراريه وسيتم العمل
على كل ذلك بقياده الدنمارك وهولندا لكنه
جهد دولي ونحن نرى دولا اخرى تريد
المساهمه في ذلك
وفي المقابل قال رئيس هيئه الاركان
الامريكيه المشتركه الجنرال مارك ميلي
اوكرانيا تستحق قوه جويه قادره لكن
التشكيل هذه القوه سيستغرق بعض الوقت
واضاف ان منافسه روسيا في الجو غير مجديه
وتتطلب الكثير من الطائرات المتقدمه
فتكلفه عشر منها تساوي مليار دولار
بالاضافه لمليار اخر لخدمتها اذا نحن
نتحدث عن مليارين دولار لعشر طائرات الروس
لديهم الفن من مقاتلات الجيل الرابع واذا
كنت تريد منافسهم في الجو فتتحتاج الى عدد
كبير من مقاتلات الجيل الرابع لذلك اذا
نظرنا الى التكلفه بعين التحليل فان اذكى
شيء نفعله وبالضبط ما فعلناه ومكان
الاوكرانيين من تحقيق النجاح اوكرانيا
تستحق ان يكون لها قوه جويه قادره لكن
بناء قوه جويه بالحجم والنطاق الذي سيكون
ضروريا يستلزم وقتا طويلا
الرئيس البيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو ان
نقل الاسلحه النوويه غير الاستراتيجيه من
روسيا الى بلاده بدا بالفعل كان وزير
الدفاع الروسي والبيلاروسي قد وقع في وقت
سابق الاتفاقا لنشر صواريخ نوويه الروسيه
تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا وقال وزير الدفاع
الروسي ان الخطوه اتخذت في ظل التوتر على
حدود بلاده الغربيه واتهم الغرب بشن حرب
غير معلنه على روسيا وبيلاروسيا
نواجه اليوم بشكل مشترك الغرب الجماعي
الذي يشن عمليا حربا غير معلنه على بلدنا
نشاط النيتو العسكري قرب حدودنا ياخذ
طابعا عدوانيا متزايدا وفي ظروف تزايد
التهديدات النوويه من جانب النيتو طررنا
لاتخاذ اجراءات مضاده في المجال النووي
وبناء على قرار قاده بل لدينا نظمنا
عمليات نشر اسلحه نوويه روسيه غير
استراتيجيه على اراضي بيلاروسيا
من كيف ينضم الينا النقيب تاراس ضابط
الضابط في الجيش الاوكراني ومن موسكو
الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه بالنسبه لما يجري في وابدا
بضيف من موسكو بما يجري في ما هي الادله
التي لدى موسكو ان هذه الهجمات التي تقع
في بولغروت داخل الاراضي الروسيه هي هجمات
اوكرانيه
اوكرانيا قد هاجمون هجموا اهداف عسكريه
وانا حسب رايي عن الاوكرانيين يريدون
محاوله استعاده الاسكان موفل مدينه
لان هذه بالنسبه تمثل موقع عن اساسيا
ضروري جدا لاصطاعه
القيام بهجوم مضاد ضد الروس هذا السبب
وايضا هذا الهجوم فعلا قد بدا
التي هي
منطقه تقع على اليمين بالنسبه لاتجاه
الرئيسي وبعد ذلك انا اعتقد ان انا رايي
الشخصي الهجمات انطلقت على الاراضي السوري
الروسيه عفوا
على طول خطوط الحرب
فهي مناطقا وهذه فعلا شاهدنا مؤول
للمؤشرات على هذا الهجوم الارهابي الذي
اطلق ضد روسيا الكبرى بسبعين شخصا عبروا
الحدود الروسيه وتجرى قضاء عليهم على يد
القوات الروسيه وبالتالي هذه ما نراه
وكذلك ربما
هناك محاولات في منطقه
ازاباروجيا وهي ايضا ضمن خطوط المواجهه
وهناك نجد اتجاه
الوصول الى شبه جزيره القرم هذه اتجاهات
الرئيسيه والتي تدل على فكره التي اطلقها
الرئيس اللنسكي وايضا عن طريق
رئيسه الاركان
الاوكرانيه الذي اعتقد انه قد جرح مؤخرا
سيدتش طبعا اوكرانيا نفت اي صله اللاعب
الهجمات في بيل جرود لكن حاكم والسلطات
الروسيه تقول انها امسكت بثلاثه اوكرانيين
بجانب عدد من الروس وايضا
فيلق الوطنيين الروس الذي اعلن انه هو من
يقف وراء هذه الهجمات قال انه عبر الحدود
الى هذه المنطقه القريبه جدا من اوكرانيا
ما الذي يحققه ما يجري في بيل جرود عسكريا
للجانب الاوكراني
بعض مساءكم اولا
كما تعلمون فان هذه العمليه التي تمت ضد
منطقه قام بها مواطنون روس بالكامل وايه
مزاعم من ان الجيش الاوكراني له اي علاقه
مع هذا الهجوم هو كاذب لا اساس له ووزاره
الدفاع الروسيه قالت ايضا انها قتلت اكثر
سبعين جنديا في هذا الهجوم
لكن فيلق المطوعين الروسي
وفيلق الحريه الروسي قال انهما فقد عنصرين
فقط داخل اراضي الروسيه وبالطبع
اذا تحدث عن الاهميه العسكريه فان القيام
الفيلق الروسي هذا بالهجوم على منطقه
كما قالوا هم انهم يريدون
يريدون تامين الحدود بين روسيا واوكرانيا
وهم يريدون ايضا
ان لا يسمحوا للقوات الروسيه
بقصف المدن الامنه والمدنيين الامنين في
اوكرانيا لهذا السبب هم ينقذون ارواح
الناس الابرياء المدنيين في اوكرانيا
سيده ارطمان اوف من موسكو ايضا اعلان
الجانبين الروسي
والبيلاروسي نقل بدء نقل
الاسلحه النوويه التكتيكيه الى بيلاروسيا
ما الهدف من هذا من هذه الاسلحه ما الهدف
من الاعلان عن بدء نقلها الان
يستطيع ان نقل هذه الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه
بدا لي من قبل روسيا باتجاهها بيلاروسيا
وهذا قد جرى تاكيد ذلك قبل قليل من قبل
رئيسه بلا روسيا وهو في زياره رسميه الى
موسكو لمناسبه قمه
الرؤساء الاتحاد الاسيوي
وبالتالي الهدف ولضمان سلامه الاراضي
البيلاروسيه لان البولنديين وكذا مع
الاوكرانيين
قاموا بخلق اتحادا جديد
كان موجودا في زمن الصور الغابره
وفي
مناطقيه وهذه
دوله كبيره او منطقه كبيره تسيطر عليها
بولندا وهي ايضا اجزاء من اراضي بيلاروسيا
حاليا وبالتالي البيلاروسيا تخشى ان تحصل
عليها هجوم يقوم به البالونيون ضد اراضيهم
ومن جانب اخر على الاقل هذا هو التوضيح
الرسمي الذي يقدم ويقدم عده مرات وكذلك
هناك تفسير اخر وهو الذي قدمه الرئيس
لوكاشينكو
بانها وهذا امر تاكد ايضا على يد او على
لسان رئيس كازاخستان وهي انهم قد
انهم اقتربوا منا
روسيا وناسب حيث يمكن يشكل وكانهم دوله
واحده دوله بيلاروسيا وهذا ما قال الرئيس
كقصص وقال لدينا سلاح استراتيجي مشترك بين
روسيا وبيلاروسيا
نقيب ترسويتش من كييف ايضا ما يلفت
الانظار ما قاله الجذر المارك ميلي رئيس
الاركان الامريكي
من انه لا يمكن منافسه روسيا في الجو
يفهم الاوكرانيون مثل هذا التصريح وانه
التسليح اوكرانيا بحيث تكون قادره على
منافسه روسيا امر غير منطقي وغير اقتصادي
لانه يكلف الكثير
الجنرال
هو احد اكبر داعميه القوه العسكريه
الاوكرانيه والجنرال ميلي بدل جهودا
كبيره لتوفير السلاح الفعال والذخائر بما
في ذلك الان طائرات الاف سته عشر بالطبع
منذ انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي عندما ورثت
روسيا من الاتحاد السوفيتي اكبر عدد من
الطائرات فيها المقاتلات اوكرانيا تلقت
فقط عشره في المئه ما لدى روسيا الان لهذا
السبب نحن نحتاج الى المزيد من الدعم من
حلفائنا الغربيين للتصدي للتكتيكات
البربريه الروسيه في الجو وسبب حاجتنا الى
هذه المقاتلات والى انظمه دفاع جويه مرده
الى ان روسيا تشن هجماتها الصاروخيه والتي
تستهدف فيها المدنيين في اوكرانيا ولم
تهاجم الاهداف العسكريه واكبر عدد من
الضحايا وقع نتيجه للهجمات الجويه
والصاروخيه الروسيه تم في المدن
الاوكرانيه مثل
خارطه ومناطق اخرى
النقيب تاراس
الضبط في الجيش الاوكراني ونشكر ضيفنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه
مشاهدينا نشير الى هذه الاخبار العاجله
التي هي اوردناها قبل قليل عن عن وزاره
الخزانه الامريكيه التي قالت انها فرضت
عقوبات على افراد رؤوس مرتبطين بمجموعه
تقول الخزانه الامريكيه وفق هذه العواجل
ان العقوبات طالت قائده جماعه فاجنر في
ماري فان الاكزان
وتقول ان هذه العقوبات طالت ايضا قاعده
مجموعه فاجنر في مالي ايفان كما قلنا
ايفان
العواجل ايضا تتحدث عن ان هذه المجموعه
مجموعه فاجنر زودت قوات الدعم السريع
بمضادات دفاع جوي معنى من واشنطن مراسل
الجزيره محمد العلمي محمد تفاصيل ما اعلنت
عنه وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
ربما المثير
للاهتمام في البيان المكتوب الذي اصدرته
وزاره الماليه او الحزينه الامريكيه هو ان
هذه اول مره تقدم على فرض عقوبات لها صله
بالاقتتال الدائري في السودان
[موسيقى]
هذا اي حب مفقود بين واشنطن
حرب اوكرانيا وفي الكثير من بؤر التوتر في
القاره الافريقيه وسبق ان فرضت على بعض
اعبائها عقوبات لكن ما هو جديد هذه المره
هو عقوبات لها صله بما يدور في السودان
واتهام المجموعه بتزويد
مجموعه تدخل
السريع بصواريخ مما يعني يجعل الولايات
المتحده نعم
وهذا يعني من وجهه نظر امريكيه يجعل هناك
اطراف خارجيه لها ضلع مباشر فيما يجري في
السودان وربما
يعقد ايضا المهمه الامريكيه في محاوله
التفاوض او التاثير على الطرفين معا
والتهديد حتى بعقوبات ضدهما بسبب وجود
اطراف خارجيه عديده خارجه عن
مدى التاثير والنفوذ الامريكيين اذن
ما اعلنت عنه وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه هو
عقوبات بحق فاجنر لانها تزود الدعم السريع
بصواريخ ارجوا لكن ليست هنالك عقوبات
مماثله مثلا على اي طرف اخر يزود الجيش
السوداني باي شيء حسب بيان الخزانه
الامريكيه اليس كذلك
العابدين حتى الان ليس هناك اي اشاره الى
ان الحكومه الامريكيه او وزاره الماليه
تحديدا قد فرضت او تنوي فرض عقوبه في
المستقبل القريب على الاقل بماين من
الاطراف الداخليه في السودان او الخارجيه
التي تزود هذا الطرف او ذاك حتى هذه
اللحظه وهذه لاول مره كما اشرت هناك
عقوبات على احد الاطراف بسبب طيلتها
المباشره بالقتال في السودان ولاول مره
ايضا محمد وارجو ان تؤكد ذلك ان يقول
الامريكيون ان السلاح يصل لمن ومن من
بالفعل
لانها فعلا هذه اول
مره اجراءات امريكيه
السودان وبالاشاره بالاسم وبطبيعه السلاح
الذي تتلقاه
قوات التدخل السريع هذا هذا الكلام كيف
يمكن ان يتفاعل داخل موقف او فيما يتعلق
بموقف الاداره الامريكيه مما يجري في
السودان ام انه ليس له تاثير ان القضيه
هنا هي فاجنر فقط
لا يبدو ان الامر يتعدى وربما رساله غير
مباشره لقوات التدخل السريع اننا نعرف من
يزودكم بالسلاح لكن عدا ذلك لا يبدو ان
ذلك
يعني
سيتطرف سيتطور الى مضاعفات او تداعيات
مختلفه بحكم ان ربما ان هذا الموقف يبرز
ضعف الموقف الامريكي وقوته على التاثير
فيما يجري في السودان بحكم وجود اطراف
خارجه عن مدى قوته ونفوده وبالتالي لا
يملك الا ان يفرض عقوبات على هذه الاطراف
وليس يعني من الواضح ان هذه العقوبات
ستؤثر على مجموعه او عدد مجموعه اخرى التي
تصلح طرف اخرى في السودان انها ربما
ستتوقف عن مد احد طرفي النزاع في السودان
بالاسلحه فقط لان واشنطن فرضت او تهدد
بفرض عقوب اته لكن الموقف الامريكي فيما
يتعلق بما يجري في السودان ما زال عند
نقطه
الحياد بين الطرفين
صحيح لانه
الطرفين كما قلت ليس لا تملك واشنطن عمليا
ادوات التاثير
يعني القويه على الطرفين وحتى تهديدات
بالعقوبات لم تؤتي اكلها وحتى وساطه
الولايات المتحده في الهدنه الاولى
والثانيه لم تؤدي الى نتائج وحتى تهديد
بالعقوبات لم يؤدي الى النتائج لان واشنطن
تدرك ان
امكانيه تاثيرها على الاوضاع في السودان
متواضعه جدا ويزيد موقفها تواضعا هو وجود
اطراف خارجيه تدعم هذا الطرف هذا الطرف او
ذلك الطرف ولا تعير لمصادر القلق
الامريكيه اي اهتمام على ما يبدو لكن يعني
الى اي مدى يمكن ما الذي يمكن ان يؤثر في
الموقف الامريكي يعني هل هل
الحلفاء الاقليميون كاس اسرائيل كاميرات
لهم تاثير في هذا الموقف الذي يعترف بوجود
سلاح للدعم السريع من من فاجنر المصنفه
مجموعه ارهابيه عند الامريكان ومع ذلك ما
زال عند موقفه المحايد
حتى الان هناك اعتبارات ربما لا ندركها
جمله على الاداره الامريكيه مواقفها
الدبلوماسيه
ربما الان غياب الدبلوماسيين على الارض
وغياب تواصل الانساني مباشر مع الاطراف
المختلفه في السودان ترك لورشنطن مواقف
محدوده وامكانيه
المناوره محدوده
وبالتالي تحاول ان تحافظ على ولد الطرفين
الى اقصى حد ممكن على الاقل
ربما اهداف انسانيه وقت اطلاق النار
لفترات اطول يمكن من اجل
توفير المساعدات الانسانيه للمدنيين
والمصطفرين
والفكرار في كل مناسبه بانها ما زالت
مصممه على دعم ما تسميه التطلعات
الديمقراطيه للشعب السوداني دون ان تكشف
النقاب عن اي اجراءات ستتخذها عمليا على
الارض من اجل تفسير وترجمه ذلك الدعم لتلك
التطلعات اشكرك شكرا جزيلا محمد العلمي
مراسله الجزيره من واشنطن وذلك تعليقا على
الاخبار العاجله التي وردت قبل قليل
الخزانه الامريكيه تقول ان مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه تزود قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان بصواريخ ارض جو لمواجهه الجيش
السوداني وتفرض عقوبات على قيادات فاجنر
في دوله مالي
المجاوره بافريقيا
[موسيقى]
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الى امريكا
ماثيوم الامريكيه ماثيوم
يشكل تهديدا خطيرا للامن الاقليمي والدولي
واشدد ميلر التاكيد على ان الدبلوماسيه
تبقى السبيل الافضل لمنع ايران من حيازه
سلاح النووي وجاء ذلك بعد ساعات من كشف
طهران عن صاروخ باليستي جديد يحمل اسم
خيبر ويتزامن ذلك ايضا مع اعلان الطهران
احراز تقدم جيد بشان المفاوضات النوويه
وتبادل رسائل غير مباشره مع واشنطن هذا
واوضح الجيش الاسرائيلي ان تهديدات قيادته
لايران لا تعني ان اسرائيل بصدد شن حرب
رسائل مباشره من طهران لاعدائها عبر صاروخ
خيبر البالستي الجديد والرسائل غير مباشره
في الاسابيع الماضيه لاحياء الاتفاق
النووي الايراني وصفه هذا التدخل في
الملفات والغبار الذي يمنع رؤيه خاتمه كل
هذه الرسائل يجري حديث عن بريق امل للتوصل
ربما اخيرا الى اتفاق دبلوماسي بين واشنطن
وطهران رفع وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد الله سقف التوقعات المتفائله قال
ان تقدما جيدا حصل بشان المفاوضات النوويه
ورفع العقوبات مضيفا ان العمل جارا للتوصل
الى النص الاولي بشان اعاده احياء الاتفاق
النووي يتناغم كلامهم مع ما ورد على لسان
المتحدث الاقليمي باسم الخارجي الامريكيه
في مقابله سابقه مع الجزيره
الولايات المتحده ترى ان من الممكن ان
نتعامل مع مثلا البرنامج ناوي الايراني
عبر المفاوضات اذا رئيس بايدن هو لن يسمعه
النظام يمتلك الاسهال نوويه وهو لن يسقط
اي خيار من الطاوله ولكن الان نحن مازال
نرى ان هناك امكانيه للوصول الى الحل
الدبلوماسي عبر المفاوضه الدبلوماسيه
ستكون هذه التجربه الصاروخيه ماده اضافيه
لمساعد اسرائيل الراميه الى احباط كل
محاولات بعث الروح في الاتفاق خيبر هو
الجيل الرابع من طراز صاروخ خرم شهر يبلغ
مداه الفي كيلو متر يحمل راسا حربيا بوزن
2500 كيلو جرام يقال انه يصعب السيده فو
الصاروخ من قبل انظمه الدفاع الجوي بسبب
سرعته الفائقه الاعلان عنه سيساعد من
الحرب الكلاميه بين الطهران وتل ابيب
وسيزيد من التوتر الذي اعقب تصريحات
الرئيسي اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي حذر هيرتي
من ضربه وشيكا ضد ايران بسبب برنامجها
النووي وتقدمها في تخصيب اليورينيوم على
نحو غير مسبوق سبق ان الطهران تلك
الاتهامات المتكرره بالرد على انها حتى
اللحظه لم تتجاوز عتبه الستين في المئه
ستكرر تل ابيب مزاعمها امام الاداره
الامريكيه الاسبوع المقبل من المتوقع ان
يصل الى واشنطن مستشار الامن القومي ووزير
الشؤون الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه في مهمه
اخرى لاعاقه الحل الدبلوماسي واجهاض فرص
احياء الاتفاق النووي ماذا ستقدم او تؤخر
تلك الزياره في ملف كلما اقترب من الحل
عاده الامور الى المربع الاول لمن ستعود
الكلمه الاخيره وكم هو عمر محاولاتي مسلسل
الاحياء الموعود
من طهران الدكتور حسن احمد يانو دراسات
الشرق الاوسط في جامعه طهران ومن الناصره
جاكي خوري الكاتب المتخصص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه وابدا بضيف من طهران دكتور
حسن احمدان يعني وكاننا امام
خطابين ايرانيين خطاب لاسرائيل وخطاب
للولايات المتحده خطاب لاسرائيل عبر صاروخ
خيبر
مدى الفا كيلومتر يحمل 1500 كيلو جرام من
المتفجرات
وخطاب واشنطن تقدم في المفاوضات رسائل
ايجابيه بين الطرفين هل نحن امام ذلك
بالفعل هذين الخطبين
مساء الخير على المستوى الرسمي لا تميز
ايران كثيرا بين الموقفين الاسرائيلي
والامريكي لكن واضح ان ان لاسرائيل
قوه في باتجاه التازيم وهذا ما نشهده
اليوم من التصريحات الاسرائيليه ايران
تكرر مقوله كلاسويت ان اردت السلم عليك
الاستعداد للحرب وهي تعلن انها تريد احياء
الاتفاق النووي لكنها في نفس الوقت تثبت
ردعها الذي يبدو انه كلما ازداد التصعيد
تعلن عن شيء جديد يقول لاسرائيل بشكل محدد
لكن بشكل غير مباشر للولايات المتحده التي
لم تكف عن القول بان كل الخيارات على
الطاوله ان هناك خيار عسكري امام ايران
بان الردع الايراني سيكون
يعني سياتي بالكثير امام اعدائها ان كان
هناك اي تحرك عسكري خارج النطاق
الدبلوماسي انه ايران في النهايه
سياساتها ذات حدين الحد
الدبلوماسي الذي تريد له ان يمضي لكنها
ايضا تستعد لاسوء الخيارات وهو خيار
التصعيد العسكري ان حدث في المستقبل وما
هو تقدير الايرانيين الان للخيارين الخيار
التصعيد العسكري وخيار الحل الدبلوماسي
يبدو ان الخيارين ما زالا غير واضحين في
واشنطن ايهما سيتقدم الاداره الامريكيه
تريثت في البدء عند بدايه حكومه الرئيس
بايدن
بغيه يعني اقتطاع المزيد من التنازلات من
ايران بعدها العوده للاتفاق عندما حدثت
المظاهرات تريفت لانها كانت تضم بان
اهدافها ستحقق دون بدل الكثير من الجهود
اليوم هي مقبله على انتخابات بعد عام ونيف
ويبدو ان الرئيس بايدن لا يريد ان يدفع
كلفه السياسيه في العوده للاتفاق النووي
والعوده لاي مفاوضات مع ايران حتى
المفاوضات حول السجناء واطلاق اموال ايران
المجمده خارج حدودها اوقفتها الاداره من
التنفيذ رغم انها قبل ثلاثه اشهر وصلت
تقريبا الى الحل
نشكركم شكرا جزيلا دكتور حسن احمد
الشرقي الاوسط في جامعه طهران نتحول الى
الناصره وضيفنا جاكي خوري ايضا هنالك
ارتباك في الموقف الاسرائيلي يعني ان يخرج
رئيس الاركان ويهدد بضربه وشركه لايران ثم
يخرج الجيش ببيان ليقول ان هذا لا يعني شن
حرب كيف نفهم الموقف الاسرائيلي
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين اعتقد ان هذا
الموقف الاسرائيلي يعني معروف ليس وليس
بموقف جديد بمعنى في بعض الاحيان يختار
اساسا في اسرائيل وكذلك القيادات العسكريه
ان يتحدثوا في بعض المؤتمرات التي لها وزن
للنوع نوعي وهنالك اهتمام اعلامي كبير
فيها في كل ما يتعلق باطلاق التصريحات ولا
اتحدث هنا الان هنتهيات الجو العام في
اسرائيل لاي حرب وشيكا واضح لاي مواطن
اسرائيلي ولسنا بحاجه لان نكون خبراء في
هذا المجال انه لا توجد الان ضربه وشيكه
خاصه وان ضربها هذه بحاجه الى جانب
الاستعدادات اللوجستيه والاستدادات
العسكريه ويستعدادات ضخمه وكبيره جدا ولا
اعتقد ان اسرائيل في هذه جاهزه لهكذا
مواجهه هي ايضا بحاجه الى غطاء دولي
وبالاساس امريكي حتى تخرج الى هذه المهمه
التي قد تكون الاخطر يعني في تاريخها
بمعنى في كل مره في هنالك
العسكري لكنها لا تريد تقدما في المفاوضات
فما هي الخطه الاسرائيليه يعني ما هو
الموقف الاسرائيلي
نعم اعتقد هي حرب الحرب التي تتم بالاساس
في الخفاء ووراء الكواليس وتعترض صح
التعبير بمعنى نستمع هنا وهناك الانفجارات
قد تبدو مبهمه في مرحله ما في العمق
الايراني من خلال استهداف منشات استهداف
ايضا مواقع حساسه من خلال استهداف شخصيات
معينه دون ان تعلن اسرائيل رسميا انها
تتحمل مسؤوليه هذه العمليات وهذا امر كما
ذكرت ليس بجديد بالاضافه الى تعاون
استخبارات وعسكري قد يكون تحديدا امام
الولايات المتحده لا ننسى ان في الاسبوع
القادم مسؤول كبير في مكتب نتنياهو وهو
رئيس مجلس الامن القومي بالاضافه الى
الوزير لشهود الاستراتيجيه وهو يمكن نقول
وزير الخارجيه الفعلي والاهم بالنسبه
لنتنياهو سيصلني الى البيت الابيض لنقاط
مع مسؤولين امريكيين كبار في مقدمتهم
مستشار الامن القومي واعتقد ان الملف
الايراني سيكون على الطاوله بالاضافه الى
محاور اخرى موجوده اعتقد ان القلق
الاسرائيلي الان ليس بفعل ان البرنامج
النووي فقط وانما بفعل الامتداد الايراني
الذي يصل الان الى اتفاق مع السعوديه الى
انفتاح على عدد من الدول العربيه
مع دوله مثل مصر وبالتالي هذا هو يعني
بالاساس الان هي حرب سياسيه اكثر من
المواجهه العسكريه جاكي خوري الكاتب
المتخصص في الشؤون الاسرائيليه ضيفنا من
النصر شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الى ملف اخر اعلنت وكالته استخبارات غربيه
ان جهه سيبرانيه مدعومه من الصين تسللت
الى الشبكات البنيه التحتيه الحيويه في
الولايات المتحده هذه التطورات تتزامر مع
تحركات عسكريه الامريكيه جديده في محيط
الصين فقد بدات القوات الكوريه الجنوبيه
والامريكيه اليوم الخميس اكبر مناورات
مشتركه بالذخيره الحيه على الاطلاق
لمحاكاه التصدي لهجوم واسع النطاق من
كوريا الشماليه حسبما قالته وزاره الدفاع
في صول ويشارك نحو 2500 جندي في التدريبات
التي تستمر خمسه ايام وانطلقت في بوتشون
القريبه من الحدود مع كوريا الشماليه
وتشارك في التدريبات الدبابات ومدافع
هاودزر وطائرات المقاتله بحسب وزاره
الدفاع في كوريا الجنوبيه
رئيس مركز الصين والعولمه وسيكونوا معنا
ضيوف اخرون ربما المتحده للوقوف على حقيقه
ما يجري وابدا بك دكتور جاو من بيجين نفت
اي صله لها بهذه الهجمات السيبرانيه التي
وللمصادفه وقعت في جوام جزيره غوا التي
اقتربت منها البحريه الامريكيه الصينيه
قبل ذلك
لمسافات قريبه وهي محل قلق للصين ما
مصداقيه الروايه الصينيه بانها بريئه
تماما من هذه الهجمات السيبرانيه
شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه اول لا ينبغي لاي
طرف ان يتظاهر بانه قد استغرب ان كل دول
العالم تقوم باعمال تجسس ضد بعض الى الاخر
هذه حقيقه ثابته وليس خيال ثانيا قوام
مسلحه تماما
هي ليست مكان للسكن بل هي قلعه عسكريه
وهدف منها اي استهداف الصين والاستعداد
للحرب عند الحرب على الصين وبالتالي دون
الدخول التفاصيل استطيع القول فقط بانه
اذا اردتم ان تشكلوا خطرا او تاثير لبلد
اخر فانك سوف
تكشف وسوف يصغرى عليك وتشاهد فلا تتظاهر
بان هناك اي شخص جاهل ولا يعرف هذه هذا
الواقع في عالم اليوم
يعني بغض النظر عن من يتظاهر هنا لان
بيجين هي التي نفت لكن ايضا هنالك من يربط
بين بدء الهجوم السابراري على البنيه
التحتيه الامريكيه وعلى ما تصفه الخارجيه
الصينيه بالعيون الخمسه وهي دول
الانجلوساكسونيه امريكا استراليا
نيوزيلندا كندا وبريطانيا
هنالك من يربط بين هذا الهجوم السايبراني
وبين ما سيجري في مضيق تايوان او احتمال
غزو قريب لتايوان من قبل الصين هل توافق
على هذا الربط
اولا كل الاعضاء الدول في العيون الخمسه
الولايات المتحده بريطانيا كندا
كلها وتقريبا مع كل دول العالم الاخرى في
العالم تعرف تماما وتعترف بشكل قانوني
بشيء واحد بانه هناك فقط صين واحده وان
التايوان هي جزء من الصين وان جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه هي الممثله الوحيد الشرعي
لكل الصين وهذه الخلفيه اللي ينبغي ان
نتحدث عنها ولذلك في اي شخص يعتقد بانه
يستطيع ان يقف في طريقه
الصين ككل مقارنه بجزيره تايوان فهذا كان
يعني ياخذ كل التايوان هذا هو الموقف
السياسي انا اسال عن تحليل بعض الناس
وربطهم بعض المحللين ربطهم بين بدء عمليات
سيبرانيه على بنيه تحتيه عسكريه امريكيه
في قاعده وفي الولايات المتحده وبين غزو
وشيك لتايوان او عمليه صينيه في تايوان
هجوم صيني على تايوان لانه يعتبر كثيرون
ان الهجوم السيبراني هو مقدمه للهجوم
الحقيقي على الجزيره ما رايك
اولا ليس هناك هجوم على تايوان
فان الموقف الرسمي الصيني هو تشجيع
التوحيد السلمي لمع تايوان وبالتالي فايمن
يدعو الى مواجهه حول مضيق تايوان لا يهتم
تايوان نفسها بعض الدول الاخرى وبذلك منها
الولايات المتحده يصرون على الوضع القائم
في والعلاقات لا ينبغي ان تتغير بالقوه
ولكن ذلك لا يكون ذريعه لمنعه التوحيد
السلمي لتايوان وبالتالي علينا ان نقرا ما
بين الاسطر لنعرف ما الذي
يفعل ماذا ان الولايات المتحده والدول
الخمسه العيون الخمسه هي التي تنتهك سياسه
الصين الواحده وهي السياسه الرسميه تحت
ولد لا تقبل غيرها الصين
نشكرك شكرا جزيلا من بيجينا نائب رئيس
مركز الصين
للعولمه
من
نائب رئيس البعثه الامريكيه السابق في
بهجين مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق
لشؤون اسيا السيد سيدني اهلا وسهلا بك اذا
هنالك هجوم سيبرانيت تنفي الصين المسؤوليه
تعنى وتؤكد الولايات المتحده ان الصين تقف
وراءه برايك ما الهدف منه
الهدف من وراء هذه
الهجمات كما وصفاتها
التي اكتشفت الهجوم وهو حقن الانظمه داخله
المتحده
وخارجها هذا ما يسمى بالذئب بمظهر الحمل
كما يقولون يدخل الى الانظمه ويسيطر على
اجهزه الحواسيب
الصوت غير واضح من المصدر
ويرصد انشطه مختلفه عسكريه وبحرير مدنيه
وقادر على القاء الحاق الضرر هل نحن في
اطار عمليات تجسس وقرصنه عاديه معتاده بين
الدول ام اننا امام شيء مختلف يعتبر مقدمه
لعمليه عسكريه مثلا كما ربط بعض المحللين
بسبب حجم ونطاق هذا الهجوم
وما استهدف من انظمه هذا يتجاوز انشطه
التجسس العاديه
انها انه مجال مهم للوقت المتحده والصين
ان تتناقشاه حوله بدلا من خوض مثل هذه
الامور نشكرك شكرا جزيلا من
يجازى
الامريكيه السابق في مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه السابق لشؤون اسيا
[موسيقى]
افدى مرسل الجزيره في الرباط بان اجواء
ايجابيه سادت اليوم الرابع من اجتماعات
اللجنه المكلفه من المجلس الاعلى للدوله
بليبيا ومجلس النواب باعداد القوانين
الانتخابيه وينتظر ان تنهي اللجنه
المجتمعه في بوزنيقه جنوب الرباط اعمالها
بالتوافق على القوانين الانتخابيه التي
ستشهدها ليبيا سواء للرئاسيه او
البرلمانيه وكانت اللجنه المعروفه بلجنه 6
+ 6 اعلنت انها حققت توافقا كاملا بخصوص
النقاط المتعلقه بانتخاب رئيس البلاد
واعضاء البرلمان
في فقره في المتابعه سنسلط الضوء لاحقا
على التفاهمات التي تم التوصل اليها في
هذا الاجتماعات في بوزنيقه بشان ليبيا
ومستقبلها وانعكاسها على مستقبل صياغه
القوانين الانتخابيه في الجماهير الليبيه
[موسيقى]
الى تركيا وبعد ان ظهرت نتائج الدوري
الاول من الانتخابات تبين ان توقعاتي اغلب
استطلاعات الراي كانت خاطئه هذه
الاستطلاعات توقعت مثلا تقدم مرشح
المعارضه على الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
بنسبه مريحه ومنها من توقع فوزه من الدوري
الاول التقرير التالي يقربنا اكثر من ابرز
هذه التوقعات
[موسيقى]
49.51% للرئيس اردوغان
و44.88 لمرشح للمعارضه كمال كريجدار اوغلو
فلماذا صدمت هذه النتائج كثيرين لعبت
استطلاعات الراي قبل الاقتراع دورا كبيرا
في توجيه الراي العام نحو توقع خساره
الرئيس اردوغان في تقييم لغالبيه
استطلاعات الراي التي اجريت في تركيا قبل
الدور الاول جاءت النتيجه ان حظوظ مرشح
المعارضه للفوز بالانتخابات الرئاسيه اعلى
من حظوظ اردوغان في استطلاع لميتروبول حصل
كلجدار اوغلو على
49.1% واردوغان على
46.9% في الدور الاول مع توقع فوزك الجدار
اوغلو في الدور الثاني
بو51.3% يسود اعتقاد ان استطلاعات الراي
في تركيا مسيسه ما جعل ارقامها تثير دائما
كثيره من الشكوك لكن عوامل ثلاثه دفعت
كثيرين الى تصديقها هذه المره وهي الوضع
الاقتصادي الصعب وارتفاع الاسعار واثار زل
المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا وخلف عشرات
الالاف من القتلى والجرحى اضافه الى طول
الفتره التي قضاها الرئيس في الحكم هذا
العامل الاخير جعل استطلاعات الراي تنظيف
اتجاه الرغبه في التغيير وركزت بعض
الاستطلاعات على حوالي خمسه ملايين شاب
يصوتون لاول مره اظهر احد هذه الاستطلاعات
ان 57% من من سيصوتون لاول مره يصفون
انفسهم بالحداثيين واثنين في المئه يصفون
انفسهم بالقوميين واحد عشر في المئه يصفون
انفسهم بالمتدينين المحافظين بناء على هذه
الارقام توقعت هذه الاستطلاعات ان اغلب
الشباب سيصوتون لمرشح المعارضه استخدمت
هذه الاستطلاعات ايضا من قبل اغلب الاعلام
الغربي الذي لا يخفي رغبته في ان يرى
تجربه اردوغان تغلق في تركيا فكانت اغلب
العناوين والتعليقات تتوقع نهايه اردوغان
لكن نتائج الجوله الاولى من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه جاءت عكس التوقعات
جمهور الاتفاق
[موسيقى]
نعود الى الشمعات
الفرقاء الليبيين في بوزنيقه مدينه
بوزنيقه المغربيه جنوب
الرباط بالمغرب حيث سيحاول الفرقاء
الليبيون البناء على هذا التوافق لصياغه
القوانين الانتخابيه تمهيدا لاجراء
الانتخابات في وقت لاحق الاجتماعات
المغلقه في
بوزنيقه تعقدها ما تعرف بمجموعه السته
زائد سته وهي هيئه مكونه من سته اعضاء من
مجلس النواب ومثلهم من المجلس الاعلى
للدوله مجلس طبعا في طبرق المجلس الاعلى
للدوله في طرابلس من القوانين التي يعكف
عليها وفداء اللجنه ويعكفون على صياغتها
وقانون تنظيم الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والتشريعيه ان تجرى بشكل متزامن خلال هذا
العام ومن
والتوافق ايضا يمضي في اتجاه ان يتشكل
مجلس الامه او البرلمان من غرفتين هما
مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ بعد ضبط الاطار
القانوني الذي يحدد
يحدد ذلك الشق الاجرائي يقتضي تحديد
الدوائر الانتخابيه واعتماد اليه الترشح
وهي اما ان تكون عبر قوائم حزبيه او
ترشحات فرديه
ايضا في شق السلطه التنفيذيه يتعين
التوافق على انتخاب رئيس الدوله فضلا عن
ضبط اليه تولي
ايضا
منصب النواب في البرلمان هذا الاختراق
سيشكل تحولا كبيرا طبعا في ليبيا تبحث عن
انتخابات رئاسيه وبرلمانيه منذ مده طويله
لكن هذا الاختراق اذا تحقق فانه سيحقق هذا
الحلم الذي اصبح او كذا يكون بعيد المنال
وهو يملي على اللجنه استكمال الانتخابات
التشريعيه
والرئاسيه طبعا اللجنه سته زائد سته ينبغي
عليها ان تحسم مثلا شروط الترشح لمنصب
الرئاسه العسكريون مثلا ورموز النظام
السابق هل سيسمح لهم كذلك توسيع
يتعين عليها ايضا ان تقنع الاطراف الاخرى
في المشهد الليبي بمخرجات في حال الاتفاق
الشامل اجتماع اللجنه الحالي هو الثالث
منذ تشكيلها في مارس اذار بعد اجتماعين في
طرابلس
وايضا عقد على التوالي في الخامس من ابريل
الماضي والثاني من مايو الجاري
للحديث حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
اسطنبول لزار كريكش مدير مركز بيان
للدراسات السياسيه في ليبيا في الواقع
استاذ نزار يعني
نبره التفاؤل كبيره يعني ان تعلن هذه
اللجنه انه تم التوافق تماما
على شروط الترشح للرئاسه وللبرلمان هل هل
هل هذه اغراق في التفاؤل ام انهم ربما
يكونوا قد وصلوا الى ذلك بالفعل
هو اهلا وسهلا واظن ان التوافق الكامل
يقصدون انه هو يعني حدث شبه اجماع فيما
بينهم بمعنى انهم توافقوا اجمعوا على ذلك
لكن لم يكملوا القوانين لان باقي النص
يقول انهم يعني في صدد استكمال باقي
قوانين
يعني بعض الاعضاء يعني
حتى لا يكون حتى لا يفهم هذا امر خطا لو
سمحت يعني اجماع على انه التوافق بشان
القوانين امر مهم ام اجماع على شروط
الترشح
لا هو تعرض القضايا المطروحه في
الانتخابات وشروط الترشح ولكن لا يفهم
الكلام انه وصلوا الى نتيجه نهائيه في
المسائل العالقه مثل ازدواجيه الجنسيه او
الانتخاب العسكريين انما في الباقي الشروط
كالعمر
يعني الديانه الاهليه
الانتماءات الا يكون عليه يعني حكم جنائي
هذه الاشياء اتفقوا عليه وهذا ما حدث في
مصر من قبل ظهرت نفس اللجنه اذا في هذه
الحل التوافق هي التي كانت عاقبك ده في
طريق كل المفاوضات ما الجديد في هذه
المفاوض
في في تقدم بان هناك انتخابات متزامنه
يعني كان فيه انتخابات البرلمانيه
والرئاسيه ستجرى مع بعضها البعض لان في
الانتخابات السابقه التي الغيت كان
انتخابات الرئاسيه بقرار من البرلمان ان
يكون انتخابات رئاسيه ثم برلمانيه وهذا
احدث لغط واحدث تنافس كبير على منصب
الرئاسه وخرجت يعني اشكاليات كبيره بعض كل
طرف لا يريد الطرف الاخر ان نترشح ويضع
امامه العقبات هذا تقدم مهم التقدم الاخر
انهم يعني على الاقل انهم حددوا سقف زمني
انهم لم يكن هناك خلاف فيما بينهم مننا في
المرات السابقه كان في بعض يرفض هذه
الامور لم تعرض قضايا الحكومه التنفيذيه
في لجنه سته زي سته وهذا جيد لان من قبل
كانت الانتخابات تعرف
ينتقل البعض للقضايا السلطه التنفيذيه
يصبح النقاش في السلطه التشريعيه يتحولون
الى السلطه التنفيذيه وهذا احدث ربك
حقيقيه الان الكل يعني على الاقل في خلال
المبالغ في التفاؤل كما ذكرت لكن على
الاقل الان اصبح المقام مشترك والقاعده
منطلقين منها في الذهاب للانتخابات وفيه
حتى ضغط دوري في هذا الامر وهم يتقدمون
ونتمنى لهم النجاح يعني اشكرك شكرا جزيلا
من اسطنبول نزار كريكش مدير مركز بيان
للدراسات السياسيه في ليبيا
في هذا نصل ختام هذه الحلقه من الحصاد
دمتم في رعايه الله
[موسيقى]